instead of a role model I want to be a
real model because the role is the world
but if I'd be me I can never let anybody
down
I don't want anybody to follow me
whatsoever I don't want to honor but I
want you to do it to listen we got to
stand up at some point and just stop
stuttering to say what you mean yes say
it loud so everybody hears you can only
be wrong once we got come out there when
we got to say it's too much money here I
mean nobody should be hitting lotto 436
million and we got people starving in
the streets that is not idealistic
that's just real that is just stupid
there's no way Michael Jackson sedan or
whoever Jackson said I have a million
thousand Drupal billion dollars and then
as people starving there's no way
there's no way do these people should
own planes and their people don't have
houses apartments shacks drawers pants I
know you rich I know you got 40 billion
dollars but can you just keep it to one
house you only need one house and if you
only got two kids can you just keep it
to two rooms I mean well I have 52 rooms
and you notice somebody with no room it
just don't make sense to me it don't and
then these people celebrate Christmas
they got big trees huge trees all the
little trimmings everybody got gifts and
it's my starving and they're having a
white Christmas they're having a great
Christmas eggnog and the whole nine
that's not fair to me you just watched
two amazing clips of Tupac Shakur take
the next three minutes to sit quietly
and think about how you can apply them
to your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]